how're you guys doing today good thank
you
I'm jumping right on in and I want to
say before I get started as you probably
heard in the other interviews when it be
huge thank you to Kia and the Kia
Telluride for being awesome sponsors the
only reason we get to be here is because
of sponsors it's expensive to cover
Sundance
thank you care right and I know they say
thank you for that too so I first want
to say congrats on the movie it is you
guys managed to pull off this high
concept thriller in a really good way
I'm just can you sort of talk about how
the project all happened and for people
that aren't familiar with it what it's
about big question start it actually
originated from a script that this guy
named drew de Waal wrote who wrote the
day the crayons quit which is a
children's book that I read to my kids
or I used to read to my kids but really
in that script there was these five
pages which kind of lit me up which
became the movie and it was this idea
that this family had undergone this huge
trauma the character that David plays
his entire family is murdered including
storm in in the first moment of the
movie basically and then David's
character Jack Radcliffe who's a cop
receives a phone call from the dead
apparently and that struck me as an
incredibly hopeful idea in the middle of
all this darkness there was this just
sort of ray of hope and that's the idea
that kind of became the movie and I just
kept reiterating that I'm a writer
myself and I sort of took that idea I
just ran with it and ran with it and ran
with it and eventually
we became the movie that you saw and a
movie that's really stressful and dark
and intense but also a movie about how
people can sort of lift themselves up
out of the horror that they face
personally and yeah well for the two of
you what I really both enjoyed both of
your performances tremendously and you
guys have some great I'm curious there
was some scenes were you talking to each
other on the phone obviously are you
guys on set working together or were any
of it done separately to make that magic
happen
yeah we made a pact early on that you
know because there were so many phone
calls we didn't want it to feel
dismembered or dispassionate or
technical so we chose to always be on
set for each other and so even though we
weren't literally in the same room we
would we would you know often be on a
phone or in the next room and so that
you're reacting to the actors energy and
not this sort of dismembered thing that
is the phone because one of the things
for anyone who goes on to see the film
one of the challenges was that even
though we have a very close relationship
as uncle and niece we spend a lot of the
film apart and so we really wanted the
audience to feel like well that you want
them back together you can feel the love
between these two people and and and the
fact that it is really painful the fact
that they're apart and we felt the best
way to do that is to be in the vicinity
of each other and not add that technical
layer of literally you know having me
reading with the script supervisor or
you know some random personals on set
well even our lovely director who's
who's who's very good at reading lines
off but you know we really wanted to do
that for each other well talk a little
bit about one of the things that I dug
is it's a whodunit thriller in two
different time periods you know so can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the film yes so
mr. Jacob said I call from what Jack
thinks is the dead at first but
basically he's in the future and I'm in
the present so once we figure that out
we have to well uncle jack or jack has
to give Ashley clues to not only save
herself but save her family so I feel
like working on Wrinkle where we had
those alternate universes in that
time-traveling aspect really helped me
personally um throughout the film and it
was interesting to I guess partake in
because you kind of have to imagine the
unimaginable and like this is not really
realistic but we were trying to make it
realistic so it was fun I think but I
think what's cool about the film is it
plays everything very realistic with one
caveat which is there's a phone call
going on between two times right you
know I'm always curious at five a sense
of everyone and everyone in this room is
part of it but the editing room is
ultimately the final rewrite I'm curious
how things changed in the editing room
if at all the editing process was pretty
monumental because when you have a phone
call and the whole movie is based on a
phone call you could imagine a thousand
different variations of dialogue that
you didn't do in production happening in
when you record the additional dialogue
so it was like the world is your oyster
but that's also a problem because you
could imagine all kinds of things and
also I would be able to marry a phone
call from over the third act to a phone
call in the second act if I wanted to
and I did stuff like that and we just we
tried to keep this board on the wall
which looked like one of those crazy man
boards from a beautiful mind with rubber
bands going from here to there and and
every time we would change something we
had to rethink everything that was going
forward because
the nature of the sort of time-traveling
aspect of the movie the butterfly effect
II think I'm just curious though did you
do any early screenings that impacted
the finished film you know someone sees
it and they're like this doesn't work
you know what I mean yeah I mean that's
a big part of most most filmmakers
processes and was for me we showed it to
David for instance and got David's
feedback and we showed it to different
people and the producers had had their
say and their thoughts and they were
very important thoughts and we showed it
to friends and family and then we showed
it to a general audience and I read
every card that people wrote and it
influenced the way I thought about
everything so we were we were doing a
lot of major heavy lifting in the Edit
room in the beginning and for the first
couple months and after that there was a
lot of fine-tuning okay for the two of
you guys you read the script you're
getting ready to film it what are the
two scenes what does what's the scene
that you're most nervous to do prior to
shooting if at all gosh well but the
most challenging one and the one I read
and I thought oh wow that's that's quite
the scene was actually the scene we did
on the first day the scene in the diner
the two most challenging scenes that we
had to do for one reason one of them
established their relationship and we
all felt pressure to establish their
relationship in a way that we would care
going forward because they were quickly
going to vanish the jury was going to
die and we were gonna have to you know
feel for them so that there was there
was a lot of you know feeling of
pressure there and then the second scene
that we had to shoot that very same
first day was massive sea
where the Bubblegum is placed under the
table and it's like a was actually a
12-minute scene the first time I cut it
together and I actually it was
challenging but funny thing is storm
kind of on her side did it in two in two
takes and I just thought the second take
was the take and I didn't even want to
do a third take and then she said I want
four unbelievable was just a blessing to
have these two people that could
actually do this drama immediately and
they were both so engaged and it was I
just tried to stay out of their way as
much as I could because one because I
didn't have enough time to fool around
with them and to you I didn't want to
ruin that do you remember what it was I
would say the most challenging scene
that I read and then proceeded to film
and they were it was challenging reading
it and it was challenging filming it I
would say I don't want to say too much
but the scene where okay the scene where
Wilco gets shot and then my dad gets
shot and my mother gets shot and then I
run upstairs that was really challenging
for me to do but it was fun in a weird
way um but when I read it I was like oh
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
pull this off
yes I think that's in I was gonna say
it's not that's not a huge spoiler I
think that stuff's early in the film so
we find out that their mass mass
occurred early in the film we just don't
see it until late in the film you know
um one of my last things for you guys
because I have such limited time with
you guys I'm curious what it means for
each of you being at Sundance because
this is you know one of the prettiest
procedures film festivals on the planet
and getting the premiere here well it's
the perfect place for this film to come
because one of the great things about
working at Blum House as people probably
know it's very restricted budgets but
what that affords you is a huge amount
of creativity and they leave us alone to
and do our work and for the filmmaker to
really express himself or herself and to
basically make the film that's in their
head and that to me is what independent
filmmaking is which is what this
festival celebrates so brilliantly so it
feels like the absolutely right place
for us to come you walk these streets
and you know you're just surrounded by
filmmakers who had a dream that
thankfully somehow it's come to fruition
and they managed to marshal it into this
thing that can be seen on a big screen
and this is an opportunity to do that
and that's how we felt making this film
and so that's why this festival is just
you know it just feels perfect for them
I would say the same thing mr. David
said and it's just a blessing and I'm
it's my first Sundance so to be here
with them and to just be able to meet
other creatives and people I know and
just take it all in and look at the snow
is pretty cool yeah and they've said it
all for me it's my third time here and
it feels like it's all one time to me
and it's pretty wonderful I feel like
it's a great opportunity to celebrate
with the people that made the movie and
it's a dream come true it was a dream
come true to be here the first time and
it continues to be that no for me sure
um I have to wrap it you guys but I'm
just gonna say for people that watching
I know you guys made this on a budget
but it looks really good for a limited
budget like it has a nice gloss and a
shine and it's it's very well told you
know thank you thank you
um seriously thank you so much for
coming in I say congrats and good luck
being here at Sundance and enjoy the
premiere and everything that goes with
it thank you
you